the tragedy which claimed so many lives
in South Korea's capital unfolded across
a few hours from this a joyful
celebration
Grim aftermath of a fatal Stampede Sky
News has collected and analyzed social
media videos to try to show what
happened and where it took place seoul's
etawan district is the city's
International quarter at just after 10
to 10 that night crowds had been
building up for the city's first
Halloween festival since the covid-19
pandemic
now it's just after 10 p.m and you can
see here on a main street that the
crowds are already tightly packed in
alongside the Main Street there are
amazing Alleyways these roads have steep
slopes on this Alleyway you can see
hundreds of revelers gathered together
but it would be the alleyway further
down the street where the deadly Crush
would occur the epicenter is here by the
Hamilton Hotel Sky News has verified
this from videos shared on social media
that contain the hotel sign
[Applause]
shortly after half past 10 a surge in
the crowd on the main Alleyway was
captured in the footage
we know this is filmed from the alleyway
by the Hamilton Hotel because a street
view image from 2018
matches the front of the bar scene in
this footage obtained by Sky News
and just before a quarter to 11 it's
clear something is going wrong but most
people are still totally oblivious
continuing to party while ambulances
begin to arrive nearby
by quarter past 11 it become apparent to
everyone that this is a serious incident
this is filmed from here emergency
services are running to and from the
alleyway
some of the footage located here is
simply too graphic to broadcast some
people were trapped for more than an
hour and a half in the Crush
it may never become clear what caused
this event to turn so deadly but the
geography of the area and the sheer
numbers of people show that any incident
would have been difficult to resolve
quickly Ashish Joshi Sky News